okay Igor did make a draw
as yeah they traded all the pieces and
we have a guest in studio with Christian
Arthur back-to-back Victor is the
important one with the black pieces
against one of the grand Masters in this
event it wasn't easy he was putting a
lot of pressure on you especially after
this move G4 how did you assess it at
this point were you concerned at all
um yeah this is where my prep ended
actually this was still your prep yeah
well I I prepped like B3 and then it was
just 0.00 yes so that's what I was
hoping for I thought G4
I didn't think it was that good because
it wasn't a bit suspicious if you play
H5 but H5 is not an easy move to me yeah
I was thinking of H5 and I was like I
just I got too scared
for a good reason yeah it's a scary move
to make yeah and I played Basics
Bishop Basics I was debating between
Bishop Basics and Bishop D7 oh back
there but this was mostly your plan to
try to open up the position on this side
right
and uh I think this was a critical
moment after that
when he played the move Knight takes C
with it did you anticipate this move at
all did you calculate it I saw Knight
takes E5 but I was like yeah he's not
gonna play it because it just looks too
risky
um but yeah I saw up to after Bishop
takes Bishop takes C5 Pawn takes and I
saw Bishop C8 and I just saw my
calculation there and I was like okay I
don't really think I can lose this like
the center pawns look scary but the two
pieces should work out we have no idea
how to assess this position the engine
was saying more or less zero zero okay
0.3 but it doesn't really matter too
much
and then came this idea of his with
Bishop takes H7 which already it's a
step in the wrong direction But Then
followed it up with F4 this must have
shot you that was that was very
suspicious because like
like Bishop takes H7 is humanly like
it's natural yes to some extent but F4
is just like opens up the king too much
and I just feel like I mean once once I
get C4 or basically once the position
opens up it can only favor me yeah and
that was the correct assessment and
after C4 he missed this move
Knight to E2 yeah
and you finish the job with Precision
Arturo congratulations uh you must feel
quite happy quite proud about your
performance so far yeah are you speaking
in touch with your coach at all what
what is your coach telling you if I
don't have a coach actually okay yeah I
haven't had a coach well I had like two
coaches but I only worked for with them
like for like Max a month so I just like
do the opening prep myself
and yeah I mean it's working guys it's
been working out it's quite the most
yeah hopefully it continues to do that
and yeah
looking forward to the next few games
Arthur congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you uh congratulations as
well Arthur as the results are coming in
uh thinking thin here as uh the game of
uh uh has just finished
as a copian has just won
a blunder uh unfortunately by Gregory
right here he just he he well he had to
he had to play Knight to D4 and to
rather stop the pawn the idea is he's
going to take and hope that you know
somehow he's going to